[Music]
[Music]
the time [ __ ] it's that time for
your uncle Joey just when you thought it
was safe
[Music]
we do it is [ __ ]
[Music]
you
[Music]
who's better than you [ __ ] uncle
Joey here mid-afternoon little [ __ ]
bong it I'm here with my trusted Goomba
Lisa at getting ready to get the party
[ __ ] started it's a beautiful day in
Southern California I hope you're having
a good day
whoever the [ __ ] you are Bangladesh
Boston Iowa or the [ __ ] is
crack-a-lackin'
it's WK n Z coming at you [ __ ]
what's happening it's a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive I'm over here
doing some bonnets as far as edibles and
taking a day off for what they don't
work no more they don't work we'll
[ __ ] eatin I leave here I can't even
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] gelatin you
understand me it's over we're taking a
couple days off and we'll come back
stronger than ever
just little clouds of love forget the
warmup
this is the bottle warmup I'm Sam I've
been smoking dope like an animal but
we're not with a bomb for the last two
days see you gotta get back to training
I'm sorry about not posting a podcast
last night it was the world series [ __ ]
okay that's as American as it gets
ain't got time to break American
tradition cuz you guys want a [ __ ]
podcast I want to congratulate Chicago
where I shot my [ __ ] special
cuz that's a badass [ __ ] City you
understand me and I watched it it was a
great [ __ ] game I bit my toenails I
bit my fingernails I plucked my [ __ ]
ass hairs everything and the suspense
was killing me but I congratulate
Cleveland because they played like
[ __ ] savages themselves besides that
back to bondage Joey this ain't no
[ __ ] ESPN [ __ ]
tremendous to get those lungs [ __ ]
moving in this family people don't
believe me everybody wants to walk
everybody wants to run [ __ ] all that
noise you do 15 bong hits back the back
of the [ __ ] I'm giving you your lockers
and tip-top Magoo
I know [ __ ] that smoke reefer
two conditions outside the condition
themselves [ __ ] around in stairs I did
98 floors of bondage today my three
three bond hits to a [ __ ] look and
you're Manning it just keep doing
bunnies just like doing [ __ ] stairs
[Music]
you better leave by my side will pat
benatar crimes of passion I'm taking a
lazy today I'm happy you're here I
missed you [ __ ]
the weave is going into my mind a little
by little choo-choo you wanna hang out
with these [ __ ] Gentiles at a they
smoke weed hahaha go hang out with them
if you want to go deep and touch your
[ __ ] soul with reefer I got the
answer [ __ ] soon we're gonna open
up the door it's getting hot hey like
one of those Nelly songs
[Music]
your back most importantly your back
[ __ ] this [ __ ] mule was
kicking through this botany
understanding
don't forget Gemma it's the first song
today
[Music]
speaking of mules [ __ ] kicking have
you gotten your little tushy [ __ ]
horrible birthday yet if you haven't you
better get your [ __ ] together I might be
[ __ ] up but my [ __ ] is spotless
[ __ ] clean warm water in your [ __ ]
dozen wonders feed you to kick the
therapist in the [ __ ] country and
stab me it's over your [ __ ]
thought-free anyway it's nice there to
do it Barney guys take a chance Columbus
dick [ __ ] who's watching was
watching the Cubans who's watching I
can't stand you no more oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you're kidding me or what little Neil
Giraldo in the afternoon please look at
me with his little puff daddy's shirt
going when do I get a bomb hit uncle
Joey when do I get a bong hit Papa you
know in time I'm happy you hear him
saying listen anybody can just smoke pot
but smoking pot with family that takes a
complete difference [ __ ] gift
meanwhile your how were you dead that's
son psychologist you don't want to get
high with your mom miss you know you're
getting too high man she know papa was
getting high she's sucking his dick for
one moment you know some dude that most
don't want to enable it Pablo he's an
imaginary guy with a big dick he's
Mexican you know and I blows we ain't
gonna tell nobody he's done up your
mother's [ __ ] you know your mother's
secret is safe you don't happen he don't
say [ __ ] two words he just went go
home and tell his Mexican buddies some
crazy white woman lick my [ __ ] I was
[ __ ] long today we waiting for you
take that damn look it's a black dick
grab that [ __ ] mage changed the
tune but not the songs dad Bible that
that's a problem they're coming at you
right there that's the one right there
look it's coming out of your nose I like
it there you go
you think you're dealing with here joy
bananas today you think I would
periscope you with Bobby if we won how
to go into the deep murky waters this
reefer is tremendous its presidential
from [ __ ] sunset arable I still run
with the Armenians from time to time
when you want to get the real deal you
gotta go senior Armenians plus I have
nice girls over there will help you
they're not uptight I'd love with all my
heart so when you get a minute go over
this once a terrible and they got the
stars of death like my man Gino with
speed weed let's say you don't want to
sit down on where you're sitting there
you like one way I do with my life
holy [ __ ] outlaw speed with and have
Gino come up with some [ __ ] stars at
that that's the way to do it concept is
easy but you don't want to do that you
won't listen to Uncle Joe you rather go
on let's do adderall and those my focus
went focus but [ __ ] focus you smoke -
Bongo - this [ __ ]
you'll be focused for six hours
guaranteed plus you have a good time
maybe on the wrong
[Music]
huh
now straight from the [ __ ] cops the
time to reprogram your remote [ __ ]
that's boring you do the best in your
own reefer
when you board the pieces doing some
smoke some reefer see what happens you
get into that [ __ ] right there which
always here theater is always doing
bondage don't forget next Friday
just like eight tickets [ __ ] on that
11 tickets left
at The Wiltern feed and that Saturday
I'm at Foxwoods Country Club the [ __ ]
thing as it shows 7:30 we'll be out of
there by 9:00 we catch [ __ ] Conor
McGregor I'm going right to a bar where
you [ __ ] savages and we're gonna talk
[ __ ] right now
let's go up my family all of us and then
that's it that's how we do it you bet
[ __ ] uncle Joey's always
thinking about the movie then they came
to November old back down page town
Friday's one show only partly in come
and take it Comedy Festival go to
comment come and take it back down and
get tickets is 35 bucks for the whole
[ __ ] thing so you can see me Todd
Barry an improv group three guys
scratching their asses the deposit for
35 [ __ ] beans that's how I roll
people I don't [ __ ] play games with
no body
beside that what you're doing bondage
the sun shining I had Lightner young-sam
but uh beside that you gotta get your
[ __ ] together that's it
you [ __ ] twenty days away from
Thanksgiving you're [ __ ] now you know
sixty two days away from Christmas and
you sit there [ __ ] broke his [ __ ]
deccan what am i I build my life for
[ __ ] you gotta get up you gotta get up
there jump from stone
don't argue that we where is this
[ __ ] radius residential throwing
[ __ ] heat from the jumpy understand
me son said I will hand while you there
you get the purple stars the red stars
call the [ __ ] green stars whatever
color skirt here into your me we got a
podcaster do now you'll see the doctor
for I got a spot at the Comedy Store
10:45 who the [ __ ] better than you I'm
on it
happy now let's chat all [ __ ] water I
got up at 5:00 I did what I had to do I
send my emails like I still [ __ ] storm
that passed out the [ __ ] nine you
understand me but my main man is here
Mickey Betancourt I'm gonna get this
[ __ ] party started alright stay black
that's right Cox up to Chicago in the
house when I talk about the celebration
one went down last night how many people
got beat up how many people got dragged
by the [ __ ] feet Chicago but most
importantly how much beer they sold you
dirty [ __ ] I'll check in with you
guys
ten minutes youtube.com slash Church see
whatever the [ __ ] it is stay black
[Music]